hey guys Ryan right over here so today
I'm gonna be checking out another
Avengers clip I saw Marvel just released
and not that long ago don't know what
the title of this clip is actually so I
don't know what to expect but it's a
minute and a half long I'm sure it's a
minute and a half of Awesomeness
minute and a half here we go
don't compare me with Stark he's a six
break your old man's heart if I have to
it has to break anything clearly you've
never made an omelet you beat me by one
second
mr. stock it's worth comfortable
like all times this was never my life
you can still walk away from this oh we
will
you believe in peace let us keep it I
think you're confusing peace with quiet
you know what's the vibrating for I'm
glad you asked that because I wanted to
take this time to explain my evil plan
[Music]
horseshit
stand the end of the path I started us
on
there's only one path to peace
Aaron station
[Music]
we have no plans tomorrow night
sweet sweet yeah so I gotta [ __ ] say
man it's like so [ __ ] sweet it was
interesting seeing the interaction
between Ultron and Iron Man I wasn't
expecting Ultron's behavior to be like
that you know it's like he seems like a
sociable dude actually you seem like an
anti-social yet sociable dude there's
kind of humor to the performance at
times the graphics of it we're like I
don't know if I really buy it but for
the most part I still thought it'd look
pretty cool but when Tony and Ultron
start fighting that was a great [ __ ]
moment I'm excited to see that whole
fight sequence see with Scarlet Witch
does see what Quicksilver does I like
what I'm seeing at Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch they're not showing us too
much of it but what we're getting from
them is really intriguing and I really
appreciate how Quicksilver is totally
different than the one in Days of Future
past
I don't think Aaron taylor-johnson is as
strong of an actor but I could be wrong
he might pull this off even better
anyway guys thanks for mentioning that
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the Rio rejects and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter where it's so much fun
interacting with us leave a comment or
two below hit that like button subscribe
share with your friends whatever the
[ __ ] youtubers say